t'écris pas d'accord dessine alors tu
fais rien du tout tu fais rien
monsieur
désolé
nettoyer la vitre c'est ça là
c'est pour les fêtes et oui non mais moi
je vous ai pas demandé de me faire un
bonhomme de neige alors vous arrêtez un
père Noël
pour les fêtes
c'est quoi ça Père Noël attends j'ai pas
fini
c'est qui vous a dit d'écrire après les
vitres
mais arrêtez je vous dis il faut pas
faire ça mais je le fais tout seul je
suis dessinateur moi c'est pas vrai
vas-y fais-moi un truc
pour les fêtes quand même c'est plus
c'est plus gai et là tu es en train de
mixer de m'énerver là pour les fêtes là
je te dis que tu écris pas après mes
vitres c'est clair ce que je te dis
t'écris pas d'accord dessine alors tu
fais rien du tout tu fais rien d'accord
non tu comprends pas ce que je te dis si
tu te fous de ma gueule ou tu le fais
exprès vous
occupez pas qui c'est qui va me faire
un bon père Noël non monsieur je veux
rien du tout un beau père Noël un
bonhomme de neige je ne veux rien du
tout mais une femme nue énervée tout à
l'heure tu m'effaces
je vais t'en mettre un karcher
dans la gueule un karcher tout à l'heure
ça va main libre donc il se comprend pas
[Musique]